one morning in february of 12 20
the residents of the fabled silk road
city of bukhara
looked out from their battlements to
find chingus khan his younger son tolue
and a formidable mongol army camp right
in front
of the city walls chingus by the way is
the preferred way of pronouncing
the great khan's name by mongol
specialist today
it is a more accurate rendering of his
written name than genghis
now this was hundreds of miles from the
last reported sighting of chingus
and their unexpected appearance at
bukhara was a testament to the
the stamina of the mongol army which had
ridden surreptitiously across the harsh
kiskum desert and of course to the
strategic brilliance
of its leadership
malek juveni a persian scholar whose
history of the world conqueror
will be one of the key eyewitness
accounts we rely on
to tell our story in this course had
this to say
about the reaction of the citizens of
bukhara that fateful morning
when the inhabitants beheld the
surrounding countryside choked with
horsemen
and the air black as night with the dust
of cavalry fright
and panic overcame them and fear and
dread
prevailed three years later
another mongol army under the command of
generals superdai
and jebe surprised a massive kievan rus
army of
80 000 men on the banks of the kalka
river
and despite being greatly outnumbered
utterly destroyed it
this was the culmination of a brief
period of devastation unleashed without
warning
on the peoples of armenia georgia and
russia but to the mongols it was just a
sideshow
to the main campaign against the charism
shah
as subudai and jebe turned east and
headed back to koresmia
to continue the war a russian chronicler
living in the city of novgorod wrote
the tatas turned back from the danipa
river and we know not
whence they came nor where they hid
themselves again
only god knows whence he fetched them
against us for our sins
a muslim author and contemporary to all
these events ibin al-athea
was so overwhelmed by the unexpected
devastation
caused by the mongols koresbian campaign
that he lamented
it may well be that the world from now
until its end
will not experience the like of it again
hello and welcome to this course on the
mongols and how their conquest of
enormous regions of eurasia changed the
course of human history
early in the 13th century mongol armies
began to move out from their homeland on
the grasslands of mongolia
to eventually conquer all of china korea
central asia persia the middle east
georgia
armenia russia and much of eastern
europe
establishing the largest empire ever
seen
and yet as surprising and shocking as
their sudden appearance
clearly was to those they conquered the
mongols were just the latest in a long
line of
militarized pastoral nomads who had been
raiding and invading
even the most powerful sedentary states
of eurasia for a very
long time we will explore some of these
predecessors in detail
in lecture three but it's worth
mentioning them here the shongnu
shenbe the turks the uigas the kitan
and the churchian each of these were
formidable militarized confederations of
highly skilled
mounted archers under inspired
leadership and each had a
devastating impact on the peoples around
them
it was the chinese who bore the brunt of
many of these nomadic incursions
which is why they built a great wall to
help protect them
so the chinese were far less surprised
by the appearance of the mongols than
other states
further to the west
the mongols and the timurids were
destined to be the last in this long
line
they created the most influential of all
the empires of the step
empires that acted as a bridge between
the medieval world
and the early modern one that would
follow chingus khan who claimed a
mandate from heaven to rule the world
was singly responsible for creating the
mongol empire
once chingas and his successors had
created the vast mongol empire
east and west eurasia were linked
together as never before
this made possible that the diffusion
westwards of all manner of east asian
ideas
and technologies that eventually
galvanized europeans
to step out of their parochial kingdoms
and begin to explore and soon colonize
the world around them it is because of
this
unifying effect that some historians
claim the mongols as one of the
principal
architects of the modern world although
certainly not all agree
we will return to this assessment many
times in the lectures ahead
and try and reach some sort of a
conclusion by the end of the course
on whether the mongols deserve this
mantle
despite these many positive effects we
must of course acknowledge
that the mongols were horrendously
destructive
they killed millions of people and
destroyed dozens of the greatest cities
of the ancient world
along with the agricultural
infrastructure that had sustained them
for millennia
but we must weigh this against the fact
that the mongols facilitated
intensified levels of trade and exchange
between east and west
a patronized the finest artisans and
craftsmen promoted religious tolerance
and provided sufficient security across
eurasia to allow travelers like marco
polo
to undertake in safety extraordinary
journeys from one end of their empire
to the other although the mongols
distinguished themselves from those they
conquered by their
formidable military skill they also
enjoyed a more egalitarian
social structure than all the sedentary
states they
interacted with as with all other
nomadic pastors confederations
in the mongol world decisions were made
by a council of political and military
elites
including the decision as to who would
be elected great
khan this meant that although the khans
had great power and prestige
they were still regarded as first
amongst equals
mongol women also enjoyed considerable
freedom respect and influence
particularly when compared to the status
of women in most contemporary
sedentary societies there are several
examples known to us of mongol women who
gained
great political power and we shall also
meet some of these formidable
mongol queens in our course
it was partly because of these more
egalitarian social and political
structures
and the lifi of pastoral nomadism itself
that the mongols held a decided military
advantage
over even the best equipped and trained
sedentary armies
these advantages included advanced
cavalry tactics
and supreme horse riding skills enhanced
mobility and field craft skills
and their extraordinary prowess with a
composite bow and arrow
the mongols were rarely beaten in the
field and
uniquely amongst their nomadic cousins
they also acquired the skills of
siegecraft
so well they were rarely thwarted in
their attempts to capture cities
we will have much to say about these
political social and military
innovations in the lectures that follow
let me offer you a brief timeline of the
events we unfold in this course
which focuses on a period of just over
300 years
from the late 12th to the early 16th
centuries
the man who became chingus khan was born
probably in the year 1162
as temujin the son of a minor mongol
chief
over the next four decades he made many
allies and just as many enemies
as he slowly clawed his way to the top
of the mongol world
until in 1206 at the age of 44 he was
proclaimed
chingus khan the universal ruler the
strong ruler
for the next five years chingus
consolidated consolidated
his position by bringing various turkic
tribes into his coalition
and also by waging war against the ccr
tribes
that control parts of western china and
tibet
then in 1211 chingus launched his first
assault on northern china
which was under the control of the jinn
dynasty eventually capturing its
northern capital of jongdu
chingastan tried to establish friendly
commercial relations
with the shah of kresnia to the west a
huge islamic state that stretched
from the western edge of china to persia
but the shah treated chingus's invoice
so shamefully
that chingas had no option other than to
declare war after concluding this brutal
masterpiece of warfare chingus died at
in 1227
at the age of 65 in the midst of yet
another campaign
this time against the sisya in western
china
chingas's successor as khan was his
third son ogidai
who was elected in 1229. oggadai
inherited an empire some
nine million square miles in area
already four times the size of the roman
empire
but this was by no means the end of
mongol expansion
under ogdy the war in northern china was
resumed and successfully concluded
with the collapse of the jinn korea was
also conquered and far to the west
mongol armies invaded
armenia georgia and russia before
destroying the flower of european
knighthood
in major battles in poland and hungary
there is every reason to believe
that western europe was only saved from
mongol devastation
by the death of khan ogidai in 1241.
the decade between 1241 and 1251 gave
eurasia
breathing space as disagreements over
succession led to
an eruption of internal disputes between
the families
of chingus's four sons this had the
effect of turning the attention of
mongol elites inwards and away from
further expansion
but that ended in 1251 with the
succession of khan monkey
the son of chingus's youngest son tolui
upon coming to power monkey staged a
toluene revolution
that destroyed the power of rival
lineages
he then dispatched his brothers kublai
and hulugu on new campaigns of conquest
to china
and the middle east respectively kubolai
was intent upon destroying the
southern song dynasty while hulugu's
capture of baghdad in 1258
brought to an end the golden age of
islam
by the mid-13th century tensions were
running so high amongst the jinga sids
that there was no longer any possibility
of reunifying the mongol empire
which now devolved into four autonomous
khanates
the yuan dynasty ruled china and east
asia the chagati
ulus controlled central asia the
ilkinate ruled in persia and the middle
east
and the golden horde controlled the
steps of southern russia
monkey's death in 1259 led to civil war
between various factions which further
entrenched the divisions between the
khanates
kublai was eventually elected great khan
in 1260
but his position was by no means
universally accepted
kublai finally completed the conquest of
china in 1274
63 years after chingas khan had launched
his initial assault on the jin dynasty
way back in 1211. for the remainder of
his life kublai worked to expand his
domain
throughout much of east asia although
his invasions of japan and vietnam
both failed kublai died in 1294
as nominal ruler of something like
one-sixth
of the land surface of the earth
but such a massive empire rhythm with so
many factions and internal disputes
could never last and so gradually the
mongol khanates fell apart
the ill khanate in persia collapsed in
1335
and the iwan dynasty was eventually
destroyed by the chinese ming dynasty
in 1368. the chagati ulis in central
asia
suffered a much more gradual
disintegration and eventually morphed
into the heartland
of the timurud empire while the golden
horde in russia
maintained some degree of power and
prestige in the region
for almost another four centuries
the final part of our course is focused
on the conqueror timur
and his successes timur who was of
turkic mongol heritage
was born in modern uzbekistan probably
in the 1320s
and like his hero chingus khan he
gradually rose to power
through diplomacy and inter-tribal
warfare
timur was badly wounded in a battle in
the 1360s
and acquired a limp for the rest of his
life hence the name by which he is
better known in the west
timor the lame or tamerlane
timor was the last great nomadic
conqueror in world history
and in a series of major campaigns all
over eurasia he created his own enormous
empire
after his death in 1405 his sons and
grandsons ruled the
remnants of empire through to the early
16th century
with one descendant babur creating the
mughal empire in india
that would rule there until the british
turned up in the 18th century
this stand is the epic tale we unfold in
this course
frankly one of the most extraordinary
stories in the long annals
of world history in the next two
lectures
we'll explore the environmental context
in which the lifeway of
militarized nomadism emerged and the
formidable step predecessors to the
mongols
beginning with almighty
but in what remains of this first
lecture i thought it might be helpful to
try and paint a picture of the larger
geopolitical context
for the emergence of the mongols by
outlining some of the key developments
in eurasian history
over the centuries leading up to the
birth of chingas khan
practitioners in the fields of world
history and big history amongst whom i
include myself
believe that individual stories even
ones as epic as the mongols
make so much more sense when situated in
both the
environmental and geopolitical context
in which they
play out so let's pick up the story of
eurasian history
back in the third century of the common
era at a moment when all the imperial
states of afro-eurasia
were facing serious problems in china
the han dynasty collapsed in 220
after decades of poor leadership and
internal division
for the next 350 years china was divided
into a variety of
kingdoms and small dynasties with
warlords vying for power
with nomadic invaders late in the 6th
century
the buddhist sway dynasty ended this age
of disunity
restoring strong central government and
building impressive infrastructure
works like the grand canal but these put
such a strain on
conscripted peasant labor that the sway
dynasty collapsed quickly
early in the 7th century
their successes the tongue dynasty ruled
for the next three centuries
until 907 of the common era turning
china into what was undoubtedly the
wealthiest and most powerful
civilization on the planet
under the tongue china became a major
imperial power again
incorporating manchuria vietnam much of
tibet
and large regions of central asia into
the tang empire
farming became more efficient and
china's population approached
100 million by the 10th century
tong china was the most urbanized
society on the planet with the capital
changhan home to 2 million residents
innovation and commerce flourished in
the workshops of the
the many great tongue cities including
in porcelain
iron and steel silk gunpowder and
printing
the silk roads were revived and foreign
merchants established such a presence in
tongue cities
that virtually every religion of
afro-eurasia was practiced somewhere
in the country the tongue collapsed
early in the 10th century and this led
to another period of fragmentation
but this lasted for only 50 years before
the song dynasty restored order
however the song were forced to deal
with powerful and rest of militarized
nomads on their northern border
and eventually the northern half of
china was overrun by the churchian
who established their own chinese-style
jin dynasty
south of an uneasy border more or less
midway between the
huanghu the yellow river and the yangtze
river the southern song ruled a
dynamic commercial state from their
capital of linan
the modern city of hangzhou this was the
geopolitical situation in east asia
that the mongols faced when chingus khan
launched his initial raids on jin china
in 1211. in central asia meanwhile
the parthian and kushan empires were
both overrun by the sasanians
at exactly the same time that the han
dynasty was collapsing
in china the sasanians went on to create
their own impressive empire that lasted
for more than 400 years
at its peak the sasanian empire
stretched from afghanistan to the
headwaters of the tigris and euphrates
which led to conflict with the romans
the founder of the sasanian state
artasia the first
was a brilliant military leader who
fought the roman emperor
alexander severus for control of
mesopotamia and the euphrates river
became a
sort of fortified border between the two
empires
the second sassanian ruler shapur the
first triumphed over three successive
roman emperors
defeating one killing the next and
capturing the third
the silk roads remained a major land
trade route during the sasanian era
although maritime routes became more
important because
these incessant wars between the
sasanians and the romans
disrupted land-based trade the sasanians
maintained successful commercial
relationships with the tongue chinese
and with the byzantines
and between them these three imperial
powers controlled much of eurasia
from the yellow sea to the mediterranean
sea
in the mid 7th century however this
eurasian system
was upturned by the appearance of
another new power the muslims
who destroyed the sasanians and ushered
in a brand new chapter
in the history of afro-eurasia
from the 8th century through to the
arrival of the mongols in the early 13th
century
the histories of many of the states and
cultures of india asia
became interconnected by the expansion
of islam
created by muslim warriors merchants
missionaries and administrators
the vast dar al-islam the abode or the
realm of islam
became one of the most important
economic intellectual and cultural
structures
in the world dominating the western half
of africa
in the same way that the tongue dynasty
dominated the eastern
lightning fast expansion of the dara
islam was unprecedented
by 637 just five years after muhammad's
death
much of syria palestine and all of
mesopotamia have become part of the
muslim world
in the 640s much of north africa was
incorporated and by the time the
sasanian empire fell to the muslims
in 651 the dar al-islam already
stretched from the mediterranean
to afghanistan
after a period of political
consolidation islamic armies resumed the
jihad
early in the 8th century parts of
northern india were conquered in 7-11
and muslim hegemony in north africa was
extended to morocco
and then across the strait of gibraltar
and into spain
by 718. in less than a century the
islamic realm had expanded to become
the largest civilization the world had
ever seen
early muslim rulers established an
administrative structure
known as a caliphate that achieved
stability under the umayyad dynasty
which ruled from 661 to 750.
the umayyads were wealthy meccan
merchants who ruled the caliphate from
the
syrian commercial city of damascus
initially the
umayyads provided capable administrators
but during the 8th century they became
increasingly aloof and they were
overthrown by the abbasids
in 750. the abbasid dynasty then ruled
the islamic world
from their purpose-built capital of
baghdad until it
and they were destroyed by the mongols
in 1258.
the ambassadors learned from the
cultural exclusivity of the umayyads
and instituted a more cosmopolitan form
of government
in which power and administrative
responsibilities were shared more
equitably
amongst arabs persians egyptians and
mesopotamians
with a steady flow of tributary revenue
coming in from all over the islamic
world
baghdad was beautified with magnificent
buildings mosques
and squares and became one of the great
commercial
financial industrial and intellectual
cities
of the world under the abbasids millions
converted to islam
and enriched the islamic realm by
bringing into it their own cultural
traditions
this cultural and linguistic synthesis
resulted in an explosion of intellectual
activity
throughout the muslim world in a period
historian frederick starr has called
the lost enlightenment
with all of central asia and the middle
east now under the control of the
muslims
regions that for centuries have been
divided amongst different political
powers
and economic golden age also ensued
under the abbasids agriculture thrived
in egypt
syria and mesopotamia during a period
sometimes called
the medieval green revolution it was an
era of increased productivity
and population growth that stimulated
the economy of the region like never
before
increased agricultural output was
achieved by the expansion and better
maintenance of the ancient irrigation
canal systems
some of which had been in place in
mesopotamia for four thousand years by
this stage
and also by the introduction of new
methods of fertilization
and crop rotation commercial activity
also flourished across the islamic world
remember muhammad himself had been a
merchant and under the abbasids
elaborate trade networks linked all the
regions of the dara islam
together connecting them to an even
larger afro-eurasian wide
network camel caravans facilitated this
leading to the construction of thousands
of new caravan saris
and of course maritime trade became even
more prosperous after islamic sailors
adopted chinese innovations
like the compass muslim sailors and
their ships linked east and southeast
asia
to the indian ocean the persian gulf and
the coast of east africa
in a thriving commercial network
it was inevitable that the expansive
worlds of islam and tang china
would eventually need to confront each
other the tongue had reached deep into
central asia in constructing its
massive tributary empire just as the
realm of islam was expanding into the
same
region from the opposite direction an
important battle was fought in 751
between islamic and tongue chinese
forces deep in the heart of central asia
during the five-day battle of talas a
large muslim force
initially struggled to overcome a
smaller chinese army
for control of the important syria
valley the chinese forces were
eventually overwhelmed
marking the end of westwood tongue
expansion and opening up much of central
asia
to muslim penetration leading to the
further spread of islam
amongst the turkic peoples living in the
region
legend has it that amongst the chinese
captives were two paper makers
and this is how the craft of paper
making was introduced
into the islamic world over the
centuries that followed
a basic control of the caliphate became
increasingly compromised
as more and more regional islamic states
claimed autonomy
and even stopped paying their taxes to
baghdad new regional powers like the
takarids and the samanids effectively
ended any semblance of
an all-powerful caliph in baghdad
in the 10th century persian aristocrats
took over the abbasid throne
and during the following century power
passed into the hands of the seljuks
a group of militarized turks who had
converted to islam
and now occupied much of the caliphate
we'll talk more about the expansion of
the turks
in a later lecture but even though the
abbasid caliphate was fragmenting
we need to acknowledge that for about
700 years before the mongols appeared
muslim administrators maintained a
connected zone of trade
exchange and communication that
stretched from india and central
asia all the way to the pyrenees
intellectual activity flourished
and new crops agricultural technologies
and manufactured goods were
spread by merchants across an enormous
region of afro-eurasia
stimulating that world zone as never
before
any hope that this golden age of islam
could be maintained was destroyed in the
13th century by the mongols
as we shall see finally let's consider
the situation in europe
following the disintegration of the
roman empire
during the 5th century the western roman
empire fragmented into a series of
fortified estates and competitive
regional kingdoms
but the eastern half remained unified
and strong as the byzantine empire
which lasted for another thousand years
constantinople withstood sieges by
islamic armies in the seventh and eighth
centuries although large regions of the
empire
were lost to the muslims the core empire
survived however
and used its strategic position to
remain unconquered and wealthy
through trade and innovative
manufacturing until 1453
when constantinople was finally sacked
by the ottoman
turks further west regions of the
former roman empire gradually lost the
ability to
collect taxes or maintain a professional
army
this led to political fragmentation and
a new balance of power
between monarchs wealthy land holders
and the christian church
which now began to play an increasingly
important role in medieval
western europe the collapse of the roman
taxation and administration system
made it difficult to maintain many of
the roman cities of the west
some disappeared completely while others
broke up into areas of
smaller settlements separated by ruins
and spaces converted into
market gardens and vineyards the franks
were the first in a series of germanic
speaking dynasties to establish
successful states in western europe
under king clovis
who reigned from 481-511 and who
converted to christianity
rival frankish subgroups were
consolidated under a strong monarchy
that took control of much of gaul as far
as the rhine river
renewed frankish expansion commenced
late in the 7th century
under a new family of carolingian
leaders including
pepin ii and his son charles martel
who stopped the muslim invasion of
europe at patie
in 732 of the common era
the frankish kingdom reached its height
under charlemagne whose imperial state
included
all of modern france parts of northern
spain the territory between the rhine
and the elba
northern italy and much of the middle
danube basin
yet charlemagne's empire was fleeting
and by the late 9th century power had
reverted to a series of local princes
who lived in rural palaces in the
heartlands of their kingdoms
where their own lands and followers were
concentrated
in italy the germanic lombards lived in
cities like milan and venice
which by the 9th century had already
developed into a major commercial
port rome remained the largest city in
the west with a population of
perhaps 25 000 in the 8th century
in spain the destruction of the
visigothic kingdom by the muslims
in 7-eleven led to wholesale economic
collapse
although by the end of the 8th century
the unification of the territory
that became known as al-andalus under
the arab umayyad
emirate led to a gradual recovery
in britain many centuries of roman
occupation had increased the prosperity
of a small class of villa owners
but by the mid 5th century the breakdown
of roman control
exposed these romano british to regular
raids by picts and scots
and by anglo-saxons from the mainland by
the early 7th
century 10 or more small anglo-saxon
kingdoms
had been established in england further
north
trading and raiding in the late 8th and
early 9th centuries
brought scandinavian peoples into close
contact with communities in both western
europe
and russia political instability in
denmark resulted in expeditions by
armed bands of vikings out of
scandinavia in the mid 9th century
into their raiding and eventual
settlement in britain france and russia
wealthy monasteries were particularly
subject to viking attacks
both on the coast and in the interior as
the raiders used rivers
to move inland vikings looted paris in
845
and in the decades it followed conquered
anglo-saxon kingdoms in britain
in 878 king alfred of wessex defeated
viking forces at the battle of eddington
after which the danish king guthrum
accepted baptism
and the scandinavian presence in england
was officially recognized
as the dane law in france the land
around the city of roman
was granted in the year 911 to a viking
leader named rollo
land that eventually evolved into the
duchy of normandy
scandinavian peoples also played a
critical role in the emergence of the
first russian state
vikings established commercial bases in
ukraine and russia
and took control of regional exchange
networks establishing themselves
as the new elite that would evolve into
rulers of the first russian state
kievan rus the development of russia was
tied to the emergence of another group
destined to play an important role in
the future history of both
europe and russia the slavs who
eventually occupied a
wide region stretching from the balkans
to russia
setting up a contest for their
conversion between the pope in rome
and the patriarch in constantinople
by the mid-12th century then huge
civilizations controlled
substantial regions of eurasia including
the song and jin dynasties in east asia
the abbasid caliphate and its regional
affiliates in central and west asia
and the byzantines in the balkans but in
russia and western europe
a series of small city-states and
kingdoms had emerged
that traded and fought vigorously with
each other
with the exception of the jinn and the
song few of these great powers would
have even been aware
of the quiet step grasslands of mongolia
nor of the mongols who were just one of
several
pastoral nomadic tribes that resided
there but that was all about to change
with the birth of an infant named
temujin in the year 1162
an infant born clutching a clot of blood
in his tiny hand
a sure sign of destined greatness
[Music]
you